j'ai cru en fait être devant le journal
de 20 heures lorsque le président de la
république nous attrayant pour parler
parce sanitaires et vaccination
finalement fait un panégyrique de son
action donc nous sommes enserrée dans
des conditions discussions qui sont
draconiennes aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que notre groupe ne pourra pas dire
avant le vote des amendements six
amendements quand même six amendements
du gouvernement après une commission
mixte paritaire conclusive dont un
amendement important et donc nous
n'avons pas le loisir au moment de ce
vote de soutenir roman des amendements
les positions des uns et des autres
puisque ce sera un vote bloqué
donc nous aurons je pense à l'occasion
des explications de vote sur l'ensemble
l'occasion de dire ce que nous pensons
de la façon dont la procédure
parlementaire n'est pas respectée ou
plutôt est traitée avec légèreté par le
gouvernement mais ce que n'a pas dit le
garde des sceaux à l'instant c'est que
au fond c'est un texte d'eric
dupond-moretti pour eric dupond moretti
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on lit
finalement les seuls changements dans ce
texte c'est des changements qui vont
intéresser eric dupond-moretti
justiciables et ça il faut le dire tout
de même c'est à dire la modification que
le sénat souhaitées sur la prise
illégale d'intérêt mais aussi les
restrictions du pouvoir du parquet
national financiers enfin enfin les
encadrements de procédure lorsqu'il ya
des investigations visant des avocats
donc je pense qu'il faut être conscient
du rôle que le gouvernement fait jouer
aujourd'hui au parlement et c'est pour
cela que contraints par la procédure
extrêmement rigide de l'article 42 du
règlement je souhaitais revenir après ce
moment émouvant de panégyriques
autosatisfait du ministre
[Musique]